رئيسي مجلس الامن الروسيه الدول الغربيه
من تبعات موافقتها علشان القوات
الاوكرانيه هجمات على شبه جزيره القرم
وقال ان ذلك سيكون سببا لشن حرب وسيمنح
موسكو اطارا قانونيا للتحرك ضد الجميع
واعتبر ان هذا الامر ينبئ بان نهايه
العالم تقترب
مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي يبدا مع كامين
درغامي بطبيعه الحال سنتطرق الى التطورات
الميدانيه والقافله التي تم استهدافها وفق
الروايه الروسيه ولكن ايضا من تصريحات ما
الذي يفهم من موقف روسيا فيما يتعلق
تحديدا باي هجمات محتمله على شبه جزيره
القرن
نعم مياده تصريحات في اطار تعليق على
تصريحات المستشار في مكتب الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل قدورياك الذي قال بانه
اوكرانيا اخذت الضوء الاخضر من الشركاء
الغربيين لاستهداف العمق الروسي وتحديدا
اهداف في شبه جزيره القرمبو اعتبر هذه
التصريحات وان تطابقت مع طبعا اي توافق مع
دول الناتو بانها تعد ضوء اخضر بالنسبه
لروسيا حرب والتعامل مع الدول الغربيه
وجميع اعداء حلف النيتو على انها الدول
تعتدي على الاراضي الروسيه باعتبار ان
روسيا ترى بان شبه جزيره القرم جزء لا
يتجزا من اراضيها منذ عام 2014 لكنه ذهب
بعيدا في وصف تصريحات موبيلياك
والمؤشرات على تواصل استهداف العمق الروسي
وطبعا اهداف في شبه جزيره القرن بالقول
بان هذا يقرب نهايه العالم طبعا تصريحات
في هذا الاطار او بهذا الشكل لا تعد سابقه
باعتبار انه لطالم صعد في لهجته تجاه
الدول الغربيه تجاه الحرب النوويه تجاه اي
اصطدام محتمل مع الدول الغربيه وتحديدا
الدول النيتو وطبعا كل هذا لا يمكن فصله
عن تطورات الميدانيه التي تجري سواء في
محيط شبه جزيره القرم او في الجبهات
الجنوبيه او حتى في العمق الروسي اليوم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ومن جديد تحدثت عن
احباط محاولات اختراق او استهداف طائرات
مسيره اوكرانيه لاهداف في كل من تولا
المقاطعه تولا جنوبا موسكو وايضا في
مقاطعه بيل جراند الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا
وقالت بانها صدت كل تلك الهجمات الى ان
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي اليوم
اكد على انه احبط محاوله تنفيذ هجوم وصفه
بالارهاب على منشات في مقاطعه كلوغا التي
تقع ايضا الى الجنوب من موسكو واكد اعتقال
شخص مواطن روسي قال بانه كان على اتصال
بمجموعه ازوف القوميه الاوكرانيه التي
اعطته تعليمات بحسب قول الجهاز لتنفيذ مثل
هذه الهجمات طبعا في باقي الجبهات اليوم
وزاره الدفاع تحدثت كما اسلفت مياده عن
استهداف قافله عسكريه في احدى محطات
القطار في مقاطعه دونياس بانها دمرت عشره
مدرعات او اليات عسكريه اوكرانيه اضافه
الى مقتل 30 عسكريا اوكرانيا في هذه
الضربه التي قالت بانها تمت
بواسطه صاروخ اطلق من البر باتجاه هذا
الهدف